have you ever done something you're like
I was I was [ __ ] great in that yeah
and then go no one cared no one paid
attention no one noticed me never got
nothing all the time
really most of the time I feel that way
really not not that most the time I feel
that it was great but most of the time
when I when I have a great day where I
feel like I've done really great work I
feel like it just slides okay are you
disappointed do you want to hear
something yeah yeah it would be nice and
and I think what I do is I try to live
on
like I remember when we were doing True
Blood and speaking with some of my other
actor friends and talking about
insecurities and some of them were at
the time like IMDb still had message
boards and people would go on and read
all of these lonely angry people who
would just say terrible things about you
online and they would go and read it and
I remember sitting down with one of them
once and being like okay
you know weird guy on the internet and
Alan [ __ ] ball who keeps bringing you
back and keeps giving you challenging
material and keeps saying that you're
the [ __ ] right like at a certain point
that has to matter more his validation
of you has to matter more than this
person's and so you know what I tend to
thrive on like you know we did an
episode on Daredevil um that focused on
my character Karen Page we did a whole
backstory we took they they I will
forever be indebted to Eric Olson for
championing this to the writers who the
writer who wrote it he took the entire
crew Upstate New York in the snow and
did this amazing stand-alone story about
her past and he collaborated with me on
the story and we you know I felt
involved and creatively fulfilled by it
it was one of the best weeks of my life
in my career wow I am so [ __ ] proud
of that episode I still haven't seen it
to this day what they did with it in the
end but the experience that I had and
and working with everyone
I'll never forget it
he wrote me and said lovely things did
anyone ever mention that episode to me
outside in the public anything like that
no one no one
um but I that has to be okay right it
has to be okay okay that I'm crazy proud
that Charlie was proud of me that John
was proud of me that Vincent was proud
of me that that Eric Olson was proud of
me that you know that my husband my
family that these people you know were
proud and that has to be enough and what
you think it's like when is enough
what's enough man
ultimately you know that we get to a
point where like we have to have the
confidence and
wherewithal to sort of just say
I'm good yeah I know what I'm doing I'm
proud of myself moving on I don't need
any external validation when I've gotten
better at because because external
validation is a thing that I struggle
with I've gotten better you know when I
have those thoughts where I'm like God
damn it why couldn't that have been I go
you know what silly Deb you know what a
what a silly thought you know like this
is this person who did all this for you
he wrote this he set this side of time
he set this budget a time you know
budget aside all of this you know to do
this and that is such a huge
um vote of confidence
um that he he he did that for me so I
you know I I try to hold on to that I
have a little whenever someone sends me
a nice email I put a little a little so
I think I even call it like confidence
long or something like that and whenever
I'm having a moment I'll go read it and
it's that's smart
foreign